hello grammarians historians and
linguists david here with paige hi and
jake hey and we're going to talk about
the history of the apostrophe and the
apostrophe isn't just a punctuation mark
in fact the word apostrophe uh comes
from comes to us from greek from two
different compounds apo meaning away
and
meaning uh to turn so it's a turning of
strophene meaning to turn away so it's a
turning
away and and in rhetoric and classical
rhetoric when we talk about
apostrophe
um
it's turning away from your actual
audience to deliver a message to absent
people or inanimate objects or um
just
non-personified
you're trying to personify an inhuman
concept so before it was a punctuation
mark it was a literary technique yes it
was a turn it was a figure of speech
you know so if you think about examples
from literature this can be uh
the two things that my mind immediately
leads to being me are oh happy dagger
the speech from the end of romeo and
juliet and act five boom
sorry y'all didn't see i plunged the
stylist into my breast
oh happy dagger this is thy sheath there
rust and let me die boom so like in that
like you know we're addressing the
dagger the dagger is not alive it is a
knife it cannot respond or um
on a lighter note perhaps um from hms
pinafore there's there's a song fair
moon to the icing right regent of the
heavens it's the moon the moon can't
talk back it's it's the moon
and and from this figure of speech this
is where we get the idea that an
apostrophe represents something that is
missing
that's how we come to get its
main use to represent that something
that it's standing in for
uh absent letters just like an
apostrophe in rhetoric would be
delivered to absent friends
follow me over to the next screen let's
do a little bit of history
so the apostrophe was introduced uh to
the french language by an engraver and
humanist named joffrey torrey i think
it's how you would say his name that's a
guess in in around the late 16th century
i think is around the 1580s
tori is is the man who also introduced a
lot of diacritic or accent marks into
french so you know instead of like
mma meaning loved it would be amy like
that
and he's the person that used it
originally in french to start
representing eliminated letters
so if you have an expression like la er
meaning the hour
tori would have it
like that you know and this apostrophe
in there boom represents this missing
vowel sound
so okay so it's around this time
that
um this apostrophe starts making its way
into english because remember
england has been under french rule for
centuries at this point the french
invaded in the 11th century we're
talking about the norman conquest of
1066 and since then french culture has
had a very profound impact on the island
of great britain
uh you know so everyone in a position of
power speaks french or understands and
reads french so the nobility speaks and
reads french anyone that's literate
speaks and reads french and so you're
going to be
you know this intelligentsia is going to
be coming into contact with a lot of
french see the apostrophe being used
this way and say oh that's awfully
convenient and so it's around this time
um
around the like early 17th century late
16th century that we're starting to see
this apostrophe usage in english this is
around the time when you first see the
contraction of
i am
i'm show up is around this period
jake does this square with how
apostrophes are used in other languages
too yeah it's the same in pretty much
all the romance languages so anything
derived from latin you have in latin
uh these long
definite articles like ele i
lle
or ela i-l-l-a
and all the definite articles that come
out of this and all the romance
languages take some fraction of the
original from latin and
omit some part with an apostrophe so
amik amiko in italian
uh to make that to add a definite
article to make it the friend you can
add just l apostrophe la mico cool
so yeah so during this time
of
apostrophe expansion across the
continent people just go nuts right like
there's no standardization of usage for
apostrophes people are using it every
which way but loose you know so they're
using it like this they're using it for
contractions they're using it for
multiples of stuff like
stuff that we would consider incorrect
today like books like that
that looks terrible to me and crucially
um they're using it uh for the
possessive so like jake's
and the history of that usage is another
story entirely but this for now is the
history of the introduction of the
apostrophe into english
you can learn anything
david and company out